Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich. This is radio lab,
and today we're talking about the interior
space that runs down from your much
to your butt, and it is
called your gut. You might,
what is that? It's just an an old
person's word for mouth. Anyhow,
as we just heard for a
very, very long time,
people believed that the stomach was a
place of magical transformation. Yeah.
But of course, as we know now,
it's just a big muscle with
acid and enzymes and stuff,
but if you travel a little deeper down,
down below the stomach, yeah.
Then things get spooky
again. We just, you know, we,
we have these sort of shadowy
images of what's going on in there.
That's Carl Zimmer, a shadowy figure
himself, a science writer. And can I,
can I get some water? Yeah. And the
frequently thirsty Matt, third guy,
little scratchy Soren. And
I called him up, you know,
while you were gone on paternity leave.
Yup. And he told us you want to mystery.
Yeah, I do that. Okay. Then the
stomach is just a warmup. Oh yeah.
The 25 feet of coiled, soiled,
fitted tubing inside you. Give
me the intestines. Yeah. Yeah.
That's where the real
mystery lies, you know,
because here's the riddle is the part
of you that turns the world outside into
you, isn't just you.
It's more like a collective.
What does he mean by that? Well,
if you zoom into our
intestine [inaudible],
what you'll see is legions
of tiny creatures, bacteria,
viruses, fungi, protozoans,
and those are all little
single cell kind of guys.
We're talking about non human things
inside of me. How many of you,
how many of you guys
would you say me? Yeah,
probably in the order of maybe
a couple thousand species.
So there's Nikolai Interior Odis for
jellies and then another one, another one.
It's a whole universe down there.
Yeah. Microbacteria travel bacteria.
Your senior that follow
Caucus Chromo back the bureau.
Some of them you'll find in all of us
and then there are just a whole bunch of
other species that are rarer. Might
mean one person and not in the other.
It's like a rain forest. No. Yeah. There
are ecologists now studying your gut,
looking at these complicated networks
of hundreds of thousands of species that
are living inside of you and depending
on each other or praying on each other.
It's just this incredibly [inaudible]
complicated pattern that scientists
haven't figured out. When you're in
an embryonics in a, what is it called?
The Sachs, your amniotic
sac, your amniotic sac.
How much bacteria do you have in
about your there? You're sterile.
You have none. No, at
all. You're clean, Huh?
But then as you are,
all of a sudden you're into this
new environment. The birth canal,
you're breathing, your mouth is open,
stuff is into your mouth. It's coating
your skin. There are lots of bacteria.
There is vagina in the birth canal. It's
a very complicated ecosystem there. And
right after you were born, Chez crawl,
you meet a nurse and some doctors
who go home to play in your backyard,
you'll suck on the shoe. They might
eat some dirt and get licked by a dog.
And by the time you're going to school,
you've got probably about a hundred
Chilean micro organisms that,
so 100 trillion other kinds
of cells in you. Yeah.
So if you were to take like all the
bacteria in your body and just made them
into one lump, it would
be about three pounds.
Oh really? Think of it as an organ. I
mean, your brain is about three pounds.
Your heart, you know, hearts a pound
or two. So this is another organ.
In this case, it's an organ that helps
you digest food. But here's the thing,
this place in you which is
filled with foreign critters,
somehow this organ gets into your head.
What does that even mean?
Wait, you just wait a second.
Let me introduce you to someone. Ah,
hello. Can you hear me? Yes. Yep,
we can hear you, John. My
name is professor John Crying.
I'm a the professor and chair of Anatomy
and neuroscience here at University
College Cork in Ireland. And I'm a
neuroscientist. A brain guy. Yup.
If someone told me six years ago I
was in neuroscientist that I'd be here
talking about microbes. I
would have laughed it off.
But to make a long story short,
John found that he was
getting into neuroscience.
A lot of the neuroscientists at
his university in Cork in Ireland.
They were getting into bugs for reasons
that will become apparent in a moment.
And eventually he got the bug for
books and began to work with this one
particular strain of bacteria. The
lactobacillus strain. What was it?
Lactose something. Lactobacillus.
Lactobacillus rhamnosus.
It's looks like a pill really is kind of
oblong thing and it's sometimes used to
make yogurt. We were
interested in whether I, uh,
if you fed mice with this for
a number of weeks, whether the,
it would alter their behavioral
state, meaning if you fed these mice,
a bunch of this bacteria, would they
become very different mice? Yeah,
different mice. You mean like different
my fat or mice or something? No, no, no,
no, no. Would they change
their personalities?
This is like a profound change because
of a, a bacteria in their stomach. Yeah.
Not In their brain. No. Just in
their tummies. Just in their tummy.
That's insane. That's not going to
work. But let me tell you what he did.
All right. He had two groups of mice.
One of them got the Lactobacillus,
the others, they got
just normal mouse food.
We fed them a broth just as a control,
so it didn't have any bacteria.
Then we looked at how they
responded to a mild water stress.
And what we found was
that I [inaudible] sorry.
Well it's water. It's water
at room temperature. It's,
it's basically what he did is he took
these two groups of mice, the bacteria,
mice and the no bacteria mice.
And then he would drop
them into a of water.
And all roads are very good swimmers,
but they just don't like water. Oh.
And what he was looking for was any
difference between the two groups in terms
of how they dealt with
this water situation.
Like if one group squeaks more
than the other or something. No,
you just keep an open mind and you wait
and see what's going to happen. Fine.
So air you go. Starting with the
first group, the normal ones,
he drops them in and as you'd
expect, they try and escape.
They try and escape anytime them to
see how long they keep at it. Okay.
And one minute passes. They swim,
they swim to the edge and all around
looking for an escape. Two minutes past
three minutes path, but
about four minutes in,
he says the mice start to get worn down
and then they decide. At this point
there's no point I'm giving up.
[inaudible]
which means what? They, the,
the ordinary might just go and do a dead
mouse float. Yeah. A dead mouse flows.
You know, they just gave up. They don't
drown. No, no, no. They sit there,
sit there and think, oh, I will waiting
this out until it's over. Exactly.
It's been coined behavioral despair.
That is how a normal mouse reacts
to being tossed into water.
It struggles for about four minutes.
It gives up and then sinks into
despair for the second group.
And this is the group that
ate the bacteria. Yeah.
Dudes also drop them in the water.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Here we go.
At first he says they were
just like the first group.
They were swimming around
frantically for one minute,
two minutes, three minutes,
but then at the four minute mark when the
first group of mice had given up these
mice, they kept going.
They kept looking for an hour
past four minutes to five minutes,
six minutes. So they're
not despairing. Exactly.
And they might've kept
going on and on and on,
but he then plucked them out
of the water after six minutes.
The thing is kind of
strange. It's like, you know,
worrying and scurrying about and panicking
like that all seems like what it is
to be a mouse. And you're saying that
a bacteria in the gut can change that?
Yeah. Wait a second, Soren. Okay, fine.
There seems to be a difference between
these two groups, but how do you know?
How does John know that the bacteria
had anything to do with it? Well,
you didn't just stare at the
mice. He looked at their,
at their mouse chemistry by looking at
the stress hormones and we measured them.
What he found is that in
the first group though,
the mice that quit and despaired,
we got about a hundred fold
increase in a corticosterone levels.
That's the hormonal version of
exactly. And in that first group,
when he dropped them in the water,
their blood flooded with this one,
which initially, you know, it's not a
bad thing because a mouse has to act,
but all out panic isn't
great for a little mouse.
And after a couple of minutes of
hormone coursing through the veins,
the mouse just burns out and down.
But in the second group of mice, now
these are the mice that eat the bacteria.
We found that in the mice fed the
lactobacillus, they, well, first of all,
they had half as much of
that stress hormone half and
they had another chemical.
Suddenly in the mix, we found very,
very distinct changes in the receptors
for Gaba in a variety of brain regions.
Gabba Gabba Gabba well, he says,
you can think of it as the
opposite of a stress hormone.
It basically is there to shut down
the brain, stop things inhibit, uh,
make us more relaxed, chilled out.
And he thinks what's happening is that
in these mice that ate the bacteria,
they hit the water. The
stress hormones come online.
But before things get too intense
incomes, Gabba Gabba just goes,
hey
[inaudible].
And as a result, these mice, they're
chilled out, they're relaxed,
they're not afraid. They never
panic. They never burn out.
And they never fall into despair. They
behaved as if they were on Ballium.
So somehow the mice,
the gut bacteria of the bias
are sending volume to the brain.
Is that what he's saying? That's what
he's saying. Yeah. But you haven't,
he hasn't said anything about bacteria
yet. It's a long distance. Well,
let me get your brain up here.
John told me that if you
look inside a mouse's body,
you will find a giant nerve.
The vagus nerve that runs between
the Gus and the brain. Oh,
you mean like a phone line?
Exactly. And he thought, well,
maybe they chemically
tickle one end of the line,
send a signal up to the brain,
which then makes the Gaba.
Now in order to prove
this, he thought his mind,
I just cut the line basically
sever the Vegas nerve. Oh,
because then if the bacteria
are the ones doing it,
if he cuts the phone line they won't be
able to do it anymore and then the mind
should go back to normal. Exactly.
So in collaboration with my
colleagues at McMaster in Ontario,
he got some mice, we fed
them the bacteria again,
but this time before
throwing them into the pool,
he cut the nerve and we found that
all of the changes that we had seen,
the swimming forever,
that not giving up and the neuro
chemical changes in the brain, the Gaba,
she making them so calm.
We're completely absent. Ah,
you cut out the highway and
then the did the communication,
the grainy changes stop. Totally.
Totally. Huh. When nick got the nerve,
the mice went back to being quitters. Yep.
You have to be convinced
that. Okay, I'm convinced.
So here's my question though. This
is a mouse we're talking about.
This is just a mouse. Does this have
anything to say about us? I mean,
is there any connection to make?
Well, I asked Carl that question
there. There was one study, uh, that,
where was it? Uh, Oh, you know what? Oh,
so this was a clinical trial
actually done in France last year.
That's Jonah Lira,
who regularly reports about things in
neurological for us and, and others.
And he knew about the study too. Yes.
So they fed people just massive doses of
probiotics and probiotic mean like the
good ones versus the bad ones. Yeah.
Probiotics or the good gut bacteria.
They're in yogurt and things like
that. So these guys from France,
they gave these people packets,
like sugar sized packets of
powder inside the package.
There are two different kinds of bugs
and October facilities, Helvetica,
bifidobacterium, Longum,
two of my favorite. Yeah.
Well you should like them because I gave
them to people and they showed a fairly
dramatic reduction in their baseline
anxiety levels that became less stressful
and had less anxiety because when they
took them to high diving boards and threw
them off and fill the screen. And how
did they, how do you test these things?
Um, I say the Hopkins Symptom checklist,
basically they did a little
survey and asked questions. Uh,
how distressed do you feel? You know,
they took levels of stress hormones
on a 24 hour urinary free cortisol,
you know,
so they had some quantitative measures
and people who took those probiotics had,
they felt less angry, less
anxious, and less depressed.
So the gut bugs have us on a chain
to, yeah, cause we, you know, we have,
you know, one thing to remember
is like, you know, our mood,
a lot of the way our mood
is set is through Serotonin.
That's like when they
do antidepressant drugs,
it's the serotonin uptake something. So
you're controlling them out. Serotonin,
that's going in and out
of your neurons, right?
You have very little serotonin in your
brain, but it makes a huge difference.
You have a huge supply
of Serotonin in your gut.
80% of all the Serotonin in your
body is in your gut. Really? Yeah.
And that bacteria can be feeding on
that stuff. And you know there could be,
it could be that you know they,
you have an oil well of happiness in
your gut and if you get the right pump,
you could feel happy more of the
Times. One possibility. So Jared,
when you and I are sitting around
feeling all stressed and anxious,
or if we're just happy and, and
gay in the old sense of word,
now we know that this mood
is shadowed, influenced,
and shaped by the bacteria
you have in your intestine.
The kinds of studies
that show this effect,
they've all happened in the past
couple of years and that's it, period.
But there's this judge review.
It was in the proceedings of the
National Academy of Sciences.
It was just kind of commenting on a
couple of these studies and saying like,
hmm,
let's think about which bacteria we
should focus on for psychological
treatments.
Let's think about how we can treat
people's psychological disorders with
bacteria this way. Let's
just think about it.
This isn't the proceedings of the
National Academy of the sciences.
They're talking about treating
psychological disorders with yogurt.
Yeah, medicinal yogurt in the
future. Medicinal as in Prozac.
Sure. Medicinal as in whatever they'd
give to people with schizophrenia.
Well I don't, I mean who knows.
I mean who knows what will work
and what won't work. It's just,
but it's something that people are
saying like we need to look into this.
There's something for me,
a little poetic about the fact that a
lot of our moods come from the same organ
that produces, I mean, I haven't put my
finger on what's poetic about that, but,
but it just does kind of, I mean it,
it does make a little bit more sense
when you step back and think about this
from the spectrum of
evolution that you know,
our biggest decisions way
back when, where, what to eat,
is this gonna kill me and make
me sick? Is this food spoiled?
So it makes sense that the part of
the body which can detect that is also
intimately connected with decision making.
Systems that have to do with this
gonna make me happy or this is,
I should fear this and not eat this.
So as I landish as it seems that you know,
the self is connected with
the part of the body that it,
it also has a little bit
of engineering logic to it.
Uh Huh
[inaudible] [inaudible]
special thanks to Carl Zimmer. His
latest book is called science ink.
It's a description of tattoos that people
get on scientific themes and you can
see them on their arms, their legs,
thighs, and embarrassing places. Yes,
thanks. Also to Jonah Lehrer,
whose new book is called,
imagine how creativity works and you
can see their creativity on their nose,
eyes, cheeks, and embarrassing places.
Speaking of embarrassing places,
we're going to go to one right
now. We'll be right back.
Okay.
Special thanks to Carl Zimmer. His
latest book is called science ink.
It's a description of
tattoos that people get, uh,
on the scientific themes and you can see
them on their arms, their legs, thighs,
and embarrassing places. Yes. And thanks.